after more than a decade of talks
surrounding it the all-net resort and
Arena has a scheduled opening date so
the property headed by former NBA player
Jackie Robinson would actually bring
another professional sports arena to
Clark County Sasha Loftus has more from
the proposed site right near Las Vegas
Boulevard and Sahara
this is the lot where allnet is set to
go right between Sahara and the fountain
blue right off Las Vegas Boulevard now
this has been in the works since 2010
but those involved say the funding is
finally there won't be excited it looks
like more changes are coming to Las
Vegas yeah it's cool to see the North
End development down there after more
than a decade of talks Those Behind
all-net Resort and Arena say they're
moving forward with the massive project
on the North End of the strip we think
that Las Vegas is coming more of a
community and we need those aspects as a
community as a whole on Wednesday former
NBA player and current CEO Jackie
Robinson and his team welcome
all net resort and Arena shared these
renderings of the sports and
entertainment Arena casino free hotel
and retail shops I think the world sees
Las Vegas is a great opportunity and
this is part of that Clark County
Commissioner tick segerbloom says while
the 4.9 billion dollar project has been
pushed back before he believes secured
funding will help it move forward this
time he's been trying to work on how to
get it financed for a long time in
different ways but but as far as I can
tell and talking to people out here in
other people places the money is there
this as locals and tourists look forward
to a continued transformation and even
more opportunities in southern Nevada
it's kind of cool to see all that going
on Robinson tells me this project is set
to bring about 47 000 jobs here to Clark
County now the entire project is set to
wrap up around the end of
5. reporting off the Las Vegas Strip
social Loftus 8 News Now